professor Fergusson I think it's very
hard to think of better timing for a
book on history of Finance or the
history of money what lessons do you
think your book holds for current policy
makers and firm immortals well the
simplest lesson is that financial
history is worth knowing
sure because after all one of the causes
of the crisis that were currently living
through was a complete indifference to
financial history and a belief that in
the immortal phrase this time it's
different
I was very struck by the fact that two
years ago in late 2006 the mood in
financial markets and indeed in some
economics departments was euphoric to
the point of obliviousness of any risk
on liquidity crisis and the argument
that I went around making at that time
was that in such a highly leveraged
economy when banks and households were
accumulating so much debt and liquidity
crisis would have huge systemic impact
and these things do happen but they
don't happen so often that you can
remind your own memory as a database and
I think that's really the key to this
most people whether they're mere mortals
or masters of the universe essentially
have a knowledge of financial history
that stretches back to the beginning of
their adulthood and that's as far back
as it goes even the CEOs of the
investment banks had at most 25 years of
experience to draw on when the crisis
began in August 2007 so my sense wasn't
necessarily why I wrote the book there
might be a good idea to the data set
wordlessly larger and that a hundred
years might help them maybe 200 years
and in there and I thought well why not
do 4,000 years let's do the whole of
financial history to give people a sense
of how the process works where it came
from and why it's crisis prone but
haven't we seen a succession of
financial crises over the last 20 or 30
years we've had that the Asian crisis
and the Latin American crisis and we've
had a black Monday and the rest of it
what have you explained this mood of all
the irrational self confidence is part
of the financial people Ben Bernanke did
a lecture in 2004 with the immortal
title
the Great Moderation right in which he
pointed out that recessions
had grown shorter and less severe and
inflation had gone lower less volatile
and that this could in substantial
measure be attributed to the wisdom of
you guessed it the central bankers like
Glenn Bernanke got better at monetary
policy sort of figured it out through a
process of trial and error and I think
in the same way market participants who
had been through 1987 which was a short
very sharp stock market sell-off or who
had been through the early 90s recession
or who had been through 97-98 energy
markets and principally Asian crisis all
who had watched Wall Street recover from
9/11 which after all came in the
aftermath of a recession the feeling was
we can cope with financial crises
because all that happens in a crisis is
that the Fed cuts rates reduces the
federal funds rate and we get going
again because in effect there's a put
option out there which says you will be
able to sell your portfolio at the price
it is today not long after any financial
crisis because pretty quickly the Fed
will be able to refloat after an eclipse
so I think there was complacency because
we had withstood those crises and the
assumption was that each crisis would be
somewhat smaller and less traumatic than
the one before and this was dead wrong
because what was going on in a secular
perspective was something really very
profound and think of it as the rise and
fall of the age of leverage if you go
back further go back to the 70s the big
problem the 1970s was that financial
crisis was associated with inflation and
double-digit inflation was almost a new
war and in some countries it was
triple-digit conquering that was
extremely painful produced a big
recession in the early 1980s in most
Western countries from there on
once the inflation trap had so to speak
been sprung yeah and monetary policy had
tightened the long-term trend was for
interest rate
normal interest rates at least to go
downwards and that was an encouragement
to individuals and institutions for our
money not surprisingly and I think if
you think of it in those terms we were
going through a major transition in the
amount of debt in the economy I mean you
saw an increase in in the debt to GDP
ratio in the United States taking all
day public and private debt from
something like a hundred and fifty
percent to three hundred fifty percent
on the eve of the crisis and that was
going to be a moment when a different
kind of financial crisis struck a crisis
that would impact on the ability of
households and institutions to rollover
their debt that's why the liquidity was
the key term if there was a liquidity
crisis if it suddenly became difficult
to sell assets or to rollover debt then
the age of leverage would come to a
shuddering very painful hole Ryan that I
think was the big story that people were
missing did anything that happened in
the crisis there is an unfolding crisis
did any of that affect change your
judgment about this book but you have
changed any of the writing if you've
seen exactly how this was going to
enfold that's the challenge of writing a
financial history of the world over
thousands of years and simultaneously
keeping up to speed with an unfolding
crisis was ultimately insurmountable at
some point books after go to press and I
think I've made the last correction to
the proofs at some point in early August
that means the hook won't give you the
run down to the Lehman bankruptcy or the
small prints on the 700 billion dollar
bailout package but but I figure there
are newspapers out there that handled
that not least economists and and I was
quite happy to leave off and I left off
with a prediction of a great dying an
illusion of the book is bright this is a
quasi Darwinian process yeah always is
that in a crisis of this magnitude there
will be extinctions of species now I
think even I didn't anticipate that one
of the species that would go extinct
would be be investment that right ID
bond insurers in mind but I don't think
that that invalidates the overall
arguments so I have the opportunity to
update the paperback and bring it down
to to the latest date but it you may be
a heading for some wire yeah
target because I think the crisis is
going to be a prolonged one and it's
impossible for any historian to write
the history of the future the best you
can do is come up to the present when
you go to process sure now your last
book was on history of war and we live
in a depressingly specialized world
where historians read the financial
historians or military historians how
does this book fit into your general
corpus of work and have you dusted
justify blurring these conventional
academic boundaries
well I suppose from my very earliest
beginnings as a historian I've heard
them at least try simultaneously to
write about conflict military conflicts
and finance my PhD long ago was about
the German hyperinflation the
combinations which came in 1923 when the
German currency completely collapse but
the origins of the hyperinflation were
the first world war and the way in which
Germany financed that war and I've been
fascinated ever since that time by the
interface between geopolitics grand
strategy military matters and finance
because in the modern world I think it's
actually true in medieval world - it's
very very difficult to understand power
in the military sphere if you don't have
some understanding of power in the
financial sphere this has made me
difficult to categorize as a historian
chairs in the history of war of not
being open to me and some people in the
realm of economic history probably
regard me as insufficiently attentive to
the small print of their field but I
don't think history works well if it's
divided into these specialists and doing
little boxes it's the connections that
are interesting it's precisely the
connection between this financial crisis
and the issue of American power that is
interesting at the moment with many
people I think perhaps wrongly assuming
but a crisis of this magnitude must in
some way accelerate the decline and fall
of the American important why is money
so important to us all where did it come
from when do people start using it what
are the origins of these banknotes that
we use and are we moving towards a
cashless economy whenever I go to
Starbucks these days all these young
students or just handing over these
cards they don't seem to have money in
the way that we did we've been moving to
a cashless economy for quite a while in
the sense that most of today's money
supply and this is true of all Western
economies actually doesn't consist
nerds much less coins but all bank
deposits are current accounts and if you
measure money broadly some of our
savings accounts - most money is in fact
invisible it's we think it's in the bank
right but actually rather well-kept but
but open secret that it's not that the
bank takes our deposits and then lends
money out to other people rather higher
rate of interest and we get on the
deposits
that's how banks work so most money is
invisible money it's Bank money if you
go back 4,000 years the invention of
money I think that can be traced to
ancient Mesopotamia when for the first
time financial transactions began to be
recorded on little clay tablets and on
these clay tablets one can see hardly
sinks which essentially say pay the
bearer to the person carrying the clay
tablet a specified amount of silver or
that matter of wheat on a particular
date and it's that phrase pay the bearer
that's interesting the fact is that this
is the first attempt to institutionalize
the relationship between a creditor and
a debtor over time and space allowing a
transaction to be protracted and to be
extended and to be intermediated because
the clay tablet is some measure of
transferable it may be the bearer is not
the person who's actually around the
money now ancient stories argue about
whether this should be regarded as money
or whether these clay tablets of
something else to my mind they were the
original money and what came later coins
banknotes and then bank deposits a
really refinement of this original form
of money because it's the
institutionalization or the making
concrete of the relationship between the
debtor and the creditor that's the key
and money is really about taking that
relationship and formalizing it so that
over time and space our debts can be
settled and who invented bank codes
banknotes were invented twice at least
they existed in China
long before they existed in the West in
fact one of the characteristic features
of Imperial Chinese finance was the ease
with which paper
was adopted whereas it was only really
in the 17th century in colonial America
that the Western world started to use
banknotes and that was an expedient
caused by a really chronic shortage of
coinage it was a it was a peculiarities
of the global economy for many centuries
there's the balance of trade balance of
payments favors Asia over the West and
there was a constant drain of precious
metal from west to east to pay for the
many things that we in the West wanted
to buy from the rather more economically
advanced East and the improvisation that
went on in the Western world to try and
deal with that problem included debasing
coinage in Europe clipping it down using
the precious metal content and on the
periphery of the Western world in North
America ultimately the creation of paper
token money now at some level we we've
reached the zenith of the age of paper
money certainly the quantity of paper
money must know vastly exceed anything
that there's been in the past but I
think a really important point to grasp
is that that paper money that the
banknotes that we hand over if we rather
fashioned in Starbucks isn't quite a
small fraction of the total ratifying
most of which is in banks now throughout
the history of money there's been a
fixation on precious metals gold silver
why is this why people have this
fixation and what have been the
implications of either pegging your
currency turn said said to precious
metals or unpicking it from from gold so
the Incas were rather puzzled in the
early 16th right when the conquistadores
arrived from Spain with an apparently
insatiable craving for gold and silver
on their terrifying horses on their
other terrifying authors with their
terrifying firearms and and one of the
reasons that it was mysterious to Incas
was that the Incas could appreciate the
beauty and silver could make ornaments
out of it they had no money this was a
non-monetary economy and therefore they
couldn't quite understand the importance
that the Spaniards coming from a coin
based economy attached to gold and
silver now ever since that time that the
notion has been deeply embedded in
Western society but also in some Asian
societies
the only real money is gold and to a
lesser extent silver I mean that notion
is still very prevalent on earth many
people regard gold as the ultimate safe
haven and in times of financial crisis
we see the price of gold leap upwards
Keynes as long ago as the 1920s referred
to the gold standard in which monetary
systems around the world were pegged to
gold as a barbarous relic of an ancient
time but it's a relic that somehow
refuses to be swept away the central
banks that sold off their gold in 1999
which of course included the Bank of
England are kicking themselves because
since then private quarters left upwards
I mean the thing about gold it's not
only that it looks nice but that it's
relatively scarce there's not that much
of it and therefore you know it's a very
portable store of value as long as
people think it's nice it's really quite
a dense and compact kind of money and
that made it usually convenient as a way
of making international payments in the
time of let's say early globalization
when there was a good deal of
intercontinental trade going on but it's
still pretty risky to fill a ship with
bars of gold or chests full of gold
coins there are pirates out there things
can go wrong your ship can be can be
sunk so ultimately although gold has
this sort of almost primeval atavistic
appeal it's clearly not a particularly
convenient way of conducting
transactions and what was the
implication for Spain when they suddenly
increase the supply of gold and silver
in Europe well there was this wonderful
moment when the Spaniards thought that
they had struck it really really rich
because they found it in some of them
new conquests in Central America very
very large quantities of silver
particularly but also gold at pata sea
and what is now Bolivia there's an
enormous mountain which is that the rich
hill for silver they're still mining it
today and the demand is assumed that
since silver could be made into coins
and coins were the only real money back
in Europe they had now become
fantastically wealthier for over a
century
vast shipments went and across the
Atlantic to the Spanish ports
the Spanish government then could use
the silver to finance its wars in Europe
and it seemed as this this made Spain
and unconquerable superpower but the
quantity theory of money sector is the
more silver coins there were the less
they could each individually purchase
and Europe experienced in the so-called
price revolution the first Realtors of
inflation that had been experienced for
centuries the quantity of money in
circulation in Europe increased absurd
in the price level and so the purchasing
power of each individual unit went down
so Spain wasn't in fact vastly enriched
by the discovery of silver the price
level in Europe was substantially raised
james carville famously said you create
a mineral bulks aimless if he was going
to be in reincarnated and it's hope it
doesn't happen but if it were he wanted
to be reincarnated as the bond market
because the bond market ruled the world
what our bond markets and how did they
develop and why they conceived as being
so powerful when early Italian
city-states in the Renaissance were
waging their Wars they had a problem
which was that warmest quite expensive
usually financed with rather costly and
mercenary armies and their citizens were
reluctant to pay ever-increasing
taxation to finance these Wars one way
of solving this problem was to say well
alright just lend us the money and once
we've won the war will repay the debt
all lend us the money and we'll pay you
interest on the loan for a period of 10
20 30 years or even forever so bonds
began as a way of solving the problem of
public finance by essentially allowing
loans to substitute for taxation which
any Private Finance is essentially
driven by war in this in this society
most financial innovation until really
quite recently it has been mentioned
more than anything else by war and most
financial innovations are essentially
expedience of war finance bonds are no
exception and the history of the bond
market as it evolved from the 12th and
13th century through the Venice men
Florence and similar states that develop
bonds first spreads northward
and westwards to the Netherlands where
the United Provinces are able to finance
their fight for independence against
Spain by issuing bonds it really reaches
a kind of zenith in the 18th century and
early 19th century in Britain and it's
in Britain that we see something really
like a modern bond market emerge
standardized loans sold to the public by
a Treasury paying a predictable rate of
interest and being traded on a secondary
market that's to say the bonds are
issued people buy them at a certain
price they're then entitled to a stream
of payments interest payments on an
annual or monthly basis or quarterly
basis they can sell these bonds they
want to they decide I'd rather have the
cash that the bond is a liquid asset
this is in many ways a world that is
born in an 18th century London and the
interesting thing is there's also an
international bond market from quite an
early stage Dutch investors are drawn to
London to invest in British government
bonds now the reason that James Carville
thought the bond market was more
powerful than the police which I think
was his alternative is reincarnation
candidate has to do with the inevitable
par that any institution gets if it is
the principal source of borrowed money
for governments by the 19th century and
I try and describe this in the ascent of
money
the bond market was very large it was
very international and governments which
is pretty small tax basis really did
have to turn to this market if they
wanted to finance deficits and if the
market was in large measure dominated as
it was in say the 1820s or 1830s by one
family the Rothschild family then that
family had real power the power to say
to a government whether it was the
Prussian or Russian Brazilian for that
matter if you want to borrow a hundred
million pounds from the London bond
market we are in a sense the gatekeepers
to that market and we will determine the
price that you have to pay will
essentially determine the yield the
interest rate that you pay for the money
that you want to borrow so the bond
market became powerful I think in the
19th century it really started to be
with an autonomous force in the
International System and it has remained
powerful down to the present it had some
rough times there are times when bond
markets are vulnerable for example to
inflation but in the recent past
I'd say some four 1980s we've seen a
rise and rise of the bond market and I
think we'll see in the very near future
when a new president goes out with a
very large deficit to finance but the
bond market is just as part of maybe
more passive than it was from James
Carville said that which was right at
the beginning of the Clinton presidency
now you've written very extensively on
the the Rothschild family and their role
in the history of finance can you tell
us a little bit about this family how
did they become so important and can you
also tell us something about the
financier as pariah the feeling that
it's a group of people who somehow
respectable they look down on many of
them from ethnic minorities and of
course many of them Jewish tell us tell
us something about that that why was
that I came to the history of
Rothschilds more than ten years ago and
was enormously fortunate to be able to
work in the archives of that Bank in
London that was also material in Moscow
that had come from the Vienna house and
in Paris and in many ways the book I'm
still most proud of is the House of
Rothschild because it really did shed I
think you light on the extraordinary par
that what a family what essentially was
a family multinational was able to wield
for a period of over a hundred years and
the Rossdale banks still exist today but
they're significantly less powerful than
they were five years ago when to all
intents and purposes they were still
taken together the biggest financial
institution in the world much bigger
than JP Morgan say 100 years ago which
most people assume wasn't the most
powerful bank sentence but fascinating
thing about the history of the
Rothschilds is the interaction of myth
and reality there was indeed still is a
myth about the extraordinary power of
this family and one can still encounter
this on the Internet today that a recent
bestseller in China argues that the
Rothschilds in fact controlled the
International
which is fanciful when you look at the
size of the Rothschild Bank today it's
more a boutique than a global powerhouse
it's a tiny institutions compared with
say Goldman Sachs or for that matter
Citigroup but this myth is fascinating
because it sort of magnifies the power
of the bankers it makes it almost as if
they have total control as a result of
an elaborate conspiracy over every
single thing that happens from the
assassination of President Lincoln - oh
I don't know the assassination of John F
Kennedy the Federal Reserve is portrayed
as some kind of unquote of the of the
Jewish banking elites the book was
designed to show that these myths were
just that myths but that there was a
real financial power there and to try to
show its extent and its limits if you
are the dominant players in the 19th
century bond market as I said earlier
and you do have power if a state wants
to make a loan in some measure you
dictate the terms but over time as the
market grew larger and more players
entered as more banks were established
in relative terms the Rothschilds became
less powerful and by 1914 18 their multi
national family partnership was struck
by a fairly major thunderbolt it was
quite hard to be operating in three or
more European countries when those
countries were at war with one another
and I think one can trace a really quite
steep decline from the Rothschilds from
the first world war through the
depression to the very lean years that
London saw after the Second World War
how did they come to have this
multinational family Empire well there
was a kind of strategy Mayer Amschel
wrote childress jealous as we would now
say established a bank in Frankfurt in
the late 18th century on the back of his
antique coin dealing business he had
five sons of varying degrees of talent
and he clearly sent the most talented
Nathan to England with the view to what
we would now call internationalizing his
business by the end of the Napoleonic
period the five brothers had ended up in
five different financial centres
Frankfurt London but also Paris
Vienna and Naples which interestingly
was still seen as an important place in
the early 19th century and this gave
them a tremendous advantage over the
competition because they were able to
engage in arbitrage they could
essentially spot price differences
between the different markets and
exploit these they could tap an
international network in order to raise
money for major transactions like the
transactions which which they financed
towards the end of the Napoleonic period
so there was an element of calculation
that if you took the basic model of a
banking partnership and
internationalized it then you could you
could exploit all kinds of business
opportunities that your your your
competitors couldn't it's hard to
separate the history of Finance from the
history of certain ethnic minorities and
from auntie's anti-semitism why have
said the particular thing and when our
Snuggle was Jews but quite often Jews
played such an important role in
developing financial institutions and
what have been the consequences of that
in terms of fury on the part of people
who feel that there's some conspiracy
going on well it's as you said earlier
Adrian is that there's a prejudice
against finance in the way here
in Western civilization and a belief
which goes back a very very long way
that somehow it's preferable to be
engaged in agriculture or now factoring
than in financial services because
financial services aren't real you come
to pick them up and and carry them
around and this prejudice which i think
is a prejudice it actually makes no
sense because the financial services is
valuable economically as automobile
component this prejudice is then allied
with ethnic conflicts or ethnic
antipathy when particular minorities
play disproportionate role in the
financial system
now as you rightly related the Chinese
in not generally like this role it's
actually a characteristic feature the
ethnic groups ethnic minorities have an
inbuilt advantage when building credit
networks because minorities are often
more tightly knit as communities than
majorities and since as we said earlier
finance is partly about trust it's
striking how much more trust there can
be within an ethnic minority especially
if it's in some measure discriminated
against and that's a help plus
discrimination meant that in say
medieval Europe Jews actually couldn't
in agriculture they couldn't know that
the work there weren't eligible for
government serve and there's a premium
on putting on all your resources into
portable portable things yes I mean you
might have to hightail it out of Spain
if there's a sudden change in the law
and and Judaism is essentially
prohibited so so for all kinds of
reasons pushes and pulls Jews become
over-represented in inverted commas in
financial services it's what they're
kind of forced to do sort of what
they're good at I mean there's clearly
some kind of refinement of ability that
goes on Nathan Rothschild was a
supremely gifted mathematician he was
somebody who could calculate in really
quite a prodigious way and some writers
in this subject including my colleague
at Harvard Steve Pinker have suggested
that there is some kind of genetic
element in this but after centuries and
centuries and centuries of
specialization in this kind of business
yes Jews actually did get better at it
than than other ethnic groups so you've
got this interesting phenomenon but a
key part of the economy is
disproportionately are occupied by a
religious or ethnic minority when things
go wrong which they do in financial
history because financial markets are
crisis prone then there is a very very
straightforward way for the majority
population to react and that is to blame
the finances they don't need to be Jews
but it clearly helps the conspiracy
theory if they are and conspiracy theory
is also the tendency to replicate
themselves at the time this strangely
indestructible and so once that the myth
has been established that crises are the
fault of the Jews each time a crisis
happens somebody will will pop up to say
you see we've said this all along this
is why financial history is more than
just a narrowly dry economic subject
this is absolutely at the heart of the
culture wars of the ethnic conflicts of
medieval early modern and modern history
you can't understand anti-semitism you
can't begin to understand it if you
don't see the realities of the role of
Jews and in the financial system and
that's an important part of of what I do
in the book that's why I quote from
Shakespeare's Merchant of Venice which
in many ways establishes that the type
of the
of the ruthless an unscrupulous Jewish
moneylender in western Lucretia and I'd
be very interested to see the
consequences if we bail out having
bailed out Wall Street not bailing out
the auto industries the auto industry
how much of a sort of ethnic and
cultural complex and it's purely there
will be amongst white working-class
people in Michigan about why them not us
it's certainly the case that in most
financial crises but the losers will
tend to scapegoat
a minority group if such a minority
group is on hand all foreigners the
other way the I can work is that you say
the reason that we're going down in
Motor City is this is unfair competition
from from Asia and and I suspect that
that's increasingly the way in which
economic problems get interpreted the
tradition of blaming the Jews has in
substantial measure waned in the Western
world and it's become with good reason a
politically incorrect thing to say it's
easier to blame the Chinese for
manipulating their currency than to
blame goldman sachs for being a firm
with a substantial number of jews in its
executive tier although pat buchanan's
seemed to have a go at it well it
doesn't go away as i said it's still
there but compared the 1930 show I mean
it's really much much less legitimate
for the very obvious reason that the the
regime that took this kind of rhetoric
the furthest was diligent of Nazi
Germany and we must I think bear very
clearly in mind the catastrophic
consequences of translating and economic
crisis into the realm of ethnic conflict
as Hitler did I mean Hitler absolutely
consciously did stigmatize the Jews as
Germany's misfortune that was the slogan
that appeared at a great many Nazi
rallies through the 1930s and how much
do you think that was to do with their
preponderance role in finance was that
the thing that curated the nots is all
well there was that I mean Verna Massa
is an notable scholar in this field has
carefully documented the scale of Jewish
involvement in the German economy and
clean financial services gave was
considerable yes though not as it were
ubiquitous that there were large parts
of the German economy that really had
relatively little Jewish investment or
Jewish ownership but yeah in the banks
of Germany there was no shortage of
prominent Jewish figures the Nazis
certainly had on their side a tradition
of anti-semitism that it could build on
and a massive economic crisis that they
could blame right on on Jewish finance
but of course that was only part of it
they were also able to point out for
example that there was a substantial
number of Jews in the Bolshevik Party
and in the early Soviet regime in the
1920s for very different set of reasons
that there was a kind of Jewish
dimension to Nazi rhetoric there was
also a preoccupation which had nothing
to do with finance with intermarriage
and a fear of what used to be called
miscegenation so Nazi Nazi propaganda
about the Jews was complex but I think
it's impossible to understand it if one
doesn't see that that finance was a
critical part once again finance at the
root of so much yesterday we're going to
pause for a moment afterwards and
several other c-span programs are
available for download as podcasts visit
book TV org more with Neil Ferguson and
Adrian Wooldridge in just a moment here
are the winners of the 2008 National
Book Award and that gordon-reed wins for
nonfiction with her book the Hemings as
a Monticello you can watch her during
her four-day Thanksgiving weekend on
book TV or ad book TV org in fiction
peter matheson wins for his novel shadow
country fired fire a collection of works
from mark Doty winds in the poetry
category and in young people's
literature the winner is Judy blonde
Dells book what I saw and how I lied
afterwards with Neil Ferguson and Adrian
Wooldridge continues tell me about the
joint stock company why is it been such
a powerful such a mighty force in
economic history what is it about this
organization that makes it so
such such a tool of wealth creation you
Adrian is the author of a book on the
company hardly leading me to answer that
question but I think it's well worth
reminding viewers that the joint stock
company is a relatively recent invention
that's to say a company whose ownership
can be subdivided and sold off to
shareholders or stockholders that's
something that only begins in the early
17th century and it begins in Amsterdam
when Dutch businessman come to the
conclusion with a little bit of
political prodding that each time they
organize an expedition to Asia a trading
expedition
it's rather inconvenient and inefficient
to raise the money on an ad-hoc basis to
buy the ships to send them off to hope
that they come back Laden down with
spices so instead of doing it on that
basis they decide to pool their
resources and create a single and
ultimately ongoing entity the East India
Company and the Dutch East India Company
is the first modern company what's
what's important about is is that it
quickly becomes a perpetual concern but
there's no this is immediately true but
but after a few years they decide we're
just never going to wind this up we're
going to keep going and if you have
invested money in the company we won't
give you it back nor are we going to pay
you a guaranteed interest on your
investment you'll get a dividend if the
company is profitable in a given year if
you want your cash then you have to go
to the stock market and sell your share
your stock so we enter a new world in
which there are companies whose
ownership is quite widely distributed
and whose ownership can in fact change
over time as a result of transactions on
the stock market
why does limited liability matter so
much it matters because if limited if
liability for losses is unlimited then
you go go astray you come unstuck in a
business venture
then everything all of your assets are
up for grabs your creditors may come and
strip your house bare indeed take the
house the shirt off your back and
for the beauty of limited liability is
that it's only the money you've invested
in the company that gets lost if the
company goes belly-up your other assets
are a safe and like noids
unlike Lloyds the famous a very
antiquated model of shipping insurance
and in London which persisted with the
model of unlimited liability right down
into the late 20th century to the great
cost of those people drawn into into its
underwriting syndicate so so the limited
liability principle is a tremendously
important one because of course it
allows risks to be taken that otherwise
would be too great if all of your
capital of all of your assets are at
stake you're going to be risk averse if
you can simply say right this is going
to be invested in trade with the East
Indies and if I lose it because it's
risky then too bad but if it brings in a
big dividend a big profit then then
great the whole attitude changes towards
capitalism and since capitalism is about
taking risk in pursuit of profit and
weighing the rewards against against the
risks then limited liability and the
joint stock company are critical
inventions now you can't have joint
stock companies mad stock markets how
did stock markets develop and why a
stock markets so prone to these arash
irrational exuberance and Corrections
from the rational exuberance when early
seventeenth century Amsterdam the the
bush stock exchange springs up or less
in parallel with the East India Company
there's very quickly a secondary market
for shares in the company and this
market very quickly exhibits some of the
classic symptoms that you've just
referred to the tendency for the prices
of stock to fluctuate quite widely more
widely than say the prices of government
bonds and the bond market now the reason
for this is twofold firstly the price of
a stock in any company is essentially a
reflection of expected future earnings
to put it very very crudely those
expectations are liable to fluctuate
according to all kinds of different
variables
but the most important one is what do
you think let's say in the case of the
Dutch East India Company
what will trade be like with with Asia
in the next few years
will it be growing explosively will it
be stagnant will it collapse but the
critical point though is that we as
human beings are psychologically quite
bad at answering that question about the
future we can attach probabilities to
some parts of the question but lots of
it is simply uncertain and we don't know
for example if in the midst of a great
upswing in trade with Asia the English
are going to come along and sink half
the ships that we've we've sent out to
get spices from from the heed that's the
uncertainty that makes it very very
difficult to say anything precise about
the future so there's an element beyond
a certain point not of calculation but
of emotion and this crowd behavior I
mean everybody else you know is betting
on on the Stockton garb you tend to
wonder doing yourself it's really money
there yet the herd stampedes into the
market if it sees prices of the East
India Company stock rising there's a
self-perpetuating quality to it new
investors have drawn in seeing the
prospect of easy money and we begin to
see the origins of that that peculiar
cycle that leads from an initial
displacement a change in expectations to
a period of euphoria which produces the
bubble and suddenly the prices shoot way
beyond what really can be credible in
terms of future earnings then becomes at
the moment the reality check when people
look hard and say maybe the future isn't
quite as rosy as we thought
at which point there's a kind of check
and expectation shift the insiders begin
to sell and distress gives way to the
final phase of panic when the herd turns
around and Stampede out of the market
and the prices fall probably well below
their fair value exactly I mean it does
seem to be one of the characteristics of
money and markets and one of the reasons
why people are nervous about them that
there's an exaggeration that they tend
to magnify up up moods and magnify down
moods as well and that creates a sort of
instability right at the heart of the
economy I think that's right it was a
rather heterodox economists named Hyman
Minsky
who tried to formalize
idea that markets behave this way which
rather goes head-to-head with a
different view of the way that financial
markets work the efficient market
hypothesis which is a rather
mathematical way of thinking about the
financial world in which essentially all
information is supposed to be priced in
immediately by rational actors who have
a utility function and know exactly what
it is that they want in a liquid world
in which they can always borrow these
assumptions which underlie an entire
school of financial economics have of
course been given something of a
deathblow by by recent events and I
think hyman minsky stock if you were a
company would be would be rising rapidly
while while others have been selling off
but this is I think a really important
part of what the ascent of money is
about realizing the extent to which
financial history is as much about human
psychology life as it is about economic
rationality and the relationship between
greed and fear is absolutely crucial
here what we've seen that happen twice
in recent past we've seen it happen in
the dot-com period when people had
irrational exuberance about what Silicon
Valley's finest we're going to achieve
and it happened again in real estate
when people became irrationally
exuberant about the price of housing
it's very easy to the layman to imagine
that financial history is going to be
boring it's going to be about rather
nerdish characters who make all these
rational calculations and you look a
mess of argument to the country we
talked about the Rothschilds which are a
fascinating family on all sorts of
fronts can you tell us a little bit
about this extraordinary good John Laws
who was at the heart of one of the great
bubbles in financial history well in
many ways John law was responsible for
the original stock market bubble which
happened in Paris between 1719 and 1720
and law is a wonderful figure kind of
genius come rogue who had fled Britain
as a convicted murderer killed a man in
a duel over a woman ended up in
Amsterdam lying low
he narrowly avoided hanging escape from
jail ended up monster damned and began
to notice that the Dutch did things that
he found rather intriguing law we think
was a gambler who made his money at the
gaming table
and he began to see that there was an
even bigger game that he could play on
the Dutch stock market he began to think
seriously about about finance and began
to write about it and to make an
argument about banking that was really
rather novel he tried to sort of sell
this theory in various places including
his native Scotland and Italy without
success and finally found a buyer in
France during the period of the Regency
of the reign of Lu the 15th and the
region that Jukka volume was deeply
impressed by law who was clearly a very
bright man law made a simple argument he
said look if you only entrust
considerable economic part of me I can
solve Frances financial problems here's
what I'm going to do I'm going to create
a bank that's going to issue paper money
this was something the Dutch really
didn't do there's going to be paper
money and this will allow you to expand
the economy which is clearly been
suffering from all kinds of difficulties
at the same time I'm going to solve your
debt problems by creating a trade
company which became known as the
Mississippi company which will exploit
your territorial possessions in the new
world in what was then Louisiana
something much larger than the Louisiana
of our own time a really large tract of
the United States so law had a plan and
the plan essentially allowed him to
control D key institutions of the French
financial system he ended up controlling
not only the central bank not only the
major corporations for Mississippi
company and other related trading are
corporations but also the tax system and
even the mints that produced the French
coinage so he was in a position to say
an economy seonhwa rather as under the
fourteenth it said later the state as me
unfortunately for law he really didn't
appreciate the conflicts of interest
that were inherent in his quasi monopoly
over Frances financial institutions if
you control the central bank and the
sp500 if you're in charge of the Fed and
American corporations it is pretty
tempting especially if you're the major
shareholder in all the corporations to
lend money pretty freely and allow the
price of the shares the price of the
stock to rise matter
to the first bubble true stock market
bubble in history had its origins in an
experiment conducted by a convicted
Scottish murderer in Paris an experiment
with paper money and an equity issuance
stock issuance and he got very rich out
of this for a while he made a lot of
money he was quite a successful gambler
until the bubble burst which inevitably
it did that there comes a point when
your issuance of banknotes to finance
new purchases of new stock in your
company goes beyond the credibility of
your fundamental proposition and the
fundamental proposition was Louisiana is
a fantastic place that is going to make
France very rich indeed unfortunately
when the first settlers who were sort of
rounded up in Alsace Lorraine and sent
across the Atlantic arrived in New
Orleans new audio
named in honor of the regent they didn't
find a terribly impressive thing was
certainly not the scene that they'd been
led to expect by Mississippi company
propaganda it was a swamp and so the
initial colonization project of
Louisiana was a failure that long term
the idea was right but short term it
couldn't possibly deliver the profits
that were implied in the price of
Mississippi company's stock and the
moment that that reality dawned the
stock price began to fall and there was
nothing law could do to stop that and
boy did he try and how did his life end
at his all finish ignominy a great
flight from Paris he was rather lucky to
escape a second execution he ends up in
Venice gambling again and writing you
know the usual lamentations about his
fate it's possible to go to a church the
Church of San wisely and in Venice and
see on the floor his last resting place
which I did when I was researching the
book it's a rather moving resting place
in a way but you have to remember that
the guy underneath stone had a very
large hand in the French Revolution
because I think although of course it
happened considerably later if it hadn't
been for laws blowing up
the French financial system and he did
essentially blow it up and there would
have been a much better chance for the
French monarchy to reform its finances
in the mid to late 18th century the way
law these things the French have about a
century of chronic is not more of
chronic distrust of paper money and
stock markets and French Finance is
really sub set back into the 17th
century at a time when English finance
was making that leap forward into the
bond market that we talked about earlier
so law really although he was in many
ways a financial genius was was a
disaster for France and his experiment
went so wrong did it set France back a
good century and financial development
we haven't seen anybody quite on the
scale of law and recent history but we
have seen a number of rogues who have
created companies which are more a
little bit more like Ponzi schemes can
you tell us a little bit about any of
those companies figure I'm just thinking
of Enron which is fresh in the minds of
many people it's worth a what a Ponzi
scheme is first because in a Wailord run
upon your scheming in a Ponzi scheme you
can only pay the first loss of investors
by taking in new money from their mixed
Lahti investor's and you never actually
make any profits that you can distribute
you just keep sucking in new suckers and
this all goes back to Charles Ponzi an
immigrant to the United States who
pioneered this form of enterprise that
the story that seemed to me to be the
best modern analogue to the story of
John law was the story of Ken Lay and
Enron and I try to draw a parallel
between what happened in the late
nineties in the energy sector in the US
with what happened in France in the 1719
1720 bubble Enron really was a bubble on
top of a bubble in its share price ran
up spectacularly
on the back of the dot-com bubble when
the prices of most stocks were soaring
but the reason that Enron stocks soared
so high was that it was the product of
manipulation and indeed fraud yeah and
the story of that fraud is really rather
fascinating not a purely historical
interest but actually because it sheds
some light on our own times on the most
recent crisis one of the things that
Enron did that was in many ways most
lethal was to have off-balance-sheet
entities exactly
it would Park problem assets problem
debts and these off-balance-sheet
entities which went under all kinds of
ever more exotic names rapsa being my
favorite leah special purpose entities
as Jeffrey Skilling called them these
were absolutely the key to the company's
rise and fall once it was clear what was
going on
once the auditors were were forced by
whistleblowers to make a real assessment
of Enron's liabilities it was clear that
it's that its profits hadn't been vastly
inflated for years and were torn tense
and purposes non-existent and by 2001
the reason that interests me is that and
this was a point that Sharon Watkins one
of the Enron whistleblowers made to me
the the system of putting dodgy assets
off the balance sheet in order to make
the company's statements look good
didn't die with Enron Enron died those
responsible were jailed but this
practice in fact survived and guess
where it survived on Wall Street now
exact the practice of having off-balance
sheet vehicles with fancy names like
structured investment vehicles the same
as sins my favorite acronyms from the
crisis lives was nothing went through
them quite like the liability that these
these vehicles conduits was another
euphemism essentially allowed financial
statements to look better than they
should look these entities came flying
back onto the core balance sheet in the
liquidity crisis because they could no
longer rollover there are liabilities
there in debts and the effect was
actually devastating for the bank's it
turned their balance sheets into into a
real nightmare so I think anyone's an
interesting story not only because it
connects us to the original stock market
bubble into the world of John law it
also connects us to much more recent
events but when we are trying to
understand why it was that the balance
sheets of banks became ever more
leveraged the worse the crisis god after
August 2007 the answer lies in the Enron
onyx it had been going on in their
accounts for most people the biggest
financial investment they will make is
their house particularly in the
anglo-saxon world much more nearly a
section world in continental Europe why
this obsession was with buying your
houses
in Britain and American food
particularly in Britain if you go to
Britain it's all they talk about is
buying houses and what are the
implications for the real economy for
the broader economy of this deflation
that we're going to see in the housing
market the english-speaking world has a
real estate obsession the British have
it particularly badly but I have
encountered this in the United States -
most people will disclaim all knowledge
of Finance and indeed of economics but
on one subject they are all experts and
that is the property market the housing
market everybody is an expert on that
and everybody in 2006 that I met
including members of my own family would
assure me there was only one way that
property prices could go and Britain
could only go up and this is why it made
perfect sense to take on as large as
possible a mortgage and buyers bigger
houses you'd liked or as many houses as
you like and I felt nervous about this
every time I heard it more and more
nervous over time because it didn't seem
to me to square with historical reality
a property prices do go down there have
been lots of real estate crashes think
of Japan 1990 Britain in the early 1990s
saw a real decline in property prices of
the order of 30% I will always mystified
as to how people could forget something
that they'd lived through and yet in the
euphoria of the early 2000s the
english-speaking world came to the
conclusion that the only way you you
could lose out was to stay out of the
property market where did this obsession
come from that was a question that
really really intrigued me because I
knew enough about nineteenth and early
twentieth century history to know that
for most of the past in the
english-speaking world owning property
was a minority activity in fact it was
an aristocratic minority that owned the
land and everybody else was a tenant
whether in the countryside or in the
city when did this change when did a
majority of households become property
owners but the answer is after the
Depression and I see the ideal of the
property earning democracy as as
essentially an invention of the New Deal
of the depression and something that
gets realized only after World War two
with the great suburbanization of
England and
of America understanding this it seems
to me is really crucial if we're to
understand the current crisis because
what happened was that with every
passing decade the proportion of
households that were homeowners grew
larger and the incentive to make it
larger was primarily political by the
last decade it had become an article of
faith on also isolationist Congress both
parties took this view but it was good
to make people homeowners that it was
good for ethnic minorities to have
larger stakes in the housing market but
lending shouldn't be too tightly policed
when it came to encouraging this further
spread of property ownership and the
subprime crisis in that sense had its
origins in the realm of politics and it
was seen as a political imperative to
turn African Americans into a community
of homeowners and of course unscrupulous
lenders they made the most of this
political opportunity yes I mean it's
remarkable the way at both sides Bowman
and mrs. Thatcher of course famously
talked about the property-owning
democracy and tried to sell up council
houses but the the Labour Party was very
complicit in this this this idea that
everybody should always much manage they
counter to only as and it does seem to
be rather different situation in
continental Europe much more reluctance
to borrow a lot of money Germans are
mystified by all that the German
property market has done nothing over
the past decade or so and there has not
been a significant up shift in the
proportion of Germans who earn their own
homes
most of my German friends are happy to
to rent apartments and in that sense
before the New York model of tennessee's
is very much the norm and the other
thing that remains the case in
continental Europe is that people expect
a substantial proportion of the poorer
population to rent their homes from the
state yeah in the Britain that I grew up
in council housing was really a critical
part of the housing stock and my
grandmother I was in a council house
paying rent to a local authority in the
East End of Glasgow with certain money
in the meters so the creating money in
the middle of the gap and essentially
having minimal responsibilities of the
upkeep of the head of the property the
interesting thing is that in the you
that kind of of state-owned housing was
never so important here and I think that
reflected decisions taken the 30s when
there was an option for the New Deal to
go down the European ruler to be an
enormous expansion of the publicly
provided high air stock but instead the
Roosevelt administration went for a
rebalancing an expansion of the mortgage
market that's why the creation of Fannie
Mae is such an interesting moment in
England the New Deal the notion that
what you needed was some kind of federal
guarantee for the mortgage market if you
could create a nationwide pool of
liquidity to finance mortgages then the
mortgages would become cheaper and more
affordable for home buyers and that's an
institutional innovation that we can
create right back to the 30s but
institutional innovation that ultimately
produced a disaster because over time
Fannie Mae along with its siblings like
Freddie man became essentially a private
institution with what appeared to be a
federal guarantee and the explosion of
its balance sheet which was again
politically willed by the vote Democrats
and Republicans is a critical part of
this crisis we've seen over the last few
years an incredible increase in
sophistication of financial instruments
I mean just an extraordinary revolution
in in the amount of brain power being
applied to finance we've already we've
also seen an increase in people's
particular national institutions
appetite for risk both of these things
have been brought into a question by the
current crisis do you see a flight from
complexity and you see a flight from
risk and what are the implications of
those two things this has been an almost
evolutionary process where there has
been innovation in a very benign climate
as a whole raft of new institutions and
that instruments have been created in
the good time the age of leverage on the
institutional side you've seen a
proliferation of hedge funds private
equity partnerships under the instrument
side of course you've seen not only
derivatives that's an important part of
the story but also all kinds of bond
like the collateralized debt obligations
that were crucial to the the export of
subprime mortgages to foreign investors
but this model unquestioning they
suffered from excessive complexity and
the problem was that the complexity
didn't work
many of these instruments and
institutions had business models that
may complex mathematical assumptions
about the financial world and among
these assumptions was that the
probability of let us say the stock
market declining by 30 percent in a year
was intimate ISM this small for as
financial history tells us that that can
happen as often as seven times a century
so that the complexity was a part of the
problem but for my money the real
difficulty was but the complexity didn't
work because the mathematics that
underpinned these instruments or
underpinned the hedge-fund quantitative
models was wrong the probability of
major financial shocks was way higher
than was assumed in most of the models
on which these instruments and
institutions were built so the lesson
once again is people should spend a
little less time studying mathematics
and